Свенья Ґльоден - одна з двох мільйонів німців,
які регулярно здають кров.
Раз на три місяці вона приходить у Центр здачі крові
університетської клініки Бонна.
Процедура продумана до дрібниць.
Отримавши номерок і заповнивши формуляр з особистими і медичними даними,
Свенья прямує в реєстратуру.
Співробітниця центру звіряє дані.
У посвідченні донора вказана група крові і резус-фактор,
а також скільки разів здавалась кров.
Потім під час короткого медобстеження
у Свеньї беруть аналіз на гемоглобін,
після чого їй вимірюють тиск і температуру.
Всі показники в нормі!
Добрий ранок! Назвіть, будь ласка, ваше ім'я і прізвище.
Для Свеньї це звична процедура.
Вона здавала кров уже приблизно 40 разів.
Я намагаюсь приходити кожні три місяці.
По-перше, це добре для мого організму.
По-друге, звичайно, я хочу допомогти людям.
Адже і я сама можу опинитися в такій ситуації,
що мені знадобиться допомога.
Але не всі донори відчувають себе так спокійно.
Персонал докладає зусиль, щоб створити приємну атмосферу,
особливо для новачків.
Ми розмовляємо з ними, тут грає музика.
Ми відповідаємо на вcі запитання,
щоб донори не боялися приходити до нас.
Щоб забезпечити потреби найбільшої клініки Бонна,
потрібно близько 30 тисяч донацій крові на рік.
15 тисяч забезпечують завдяки донорам,
які приходять у центр.
Решту порції крові отримують від німецького Червоного Хреста.
Донорська кров важлива для пацієнтів,  які страждають пухлинами.
Для служб швидкої допомоги,
допомоги важко пораненим, для реанімацій.
араз німецькі клініки забезпечені донорською кров'ю
в достатній мірі, але в найближчі роки
потреба в ній, за словами професора, збільшиться
через старіння населення.
Тому роль таких донорів, як Свенья, буде зростати.
Я відчуваю себе так само добре, як і до здачі крові.
Не помітила змін.
За донацію в Німеччині не надають грошову винагороду,
але в деяких пунктах платять компенсацію за проїзд.
В університетській клініці Бонна вона становить 25 євро.
Але для Свеньї головна винагорода - не гроші,
а усвідомлення того, що вона допомагає іншим.